how you doing i'm good how are you
i'm very well thanks i'm a big fan i
like hearing that i'm a big fan of yours
as well and now a big fan of the show so
i know that you are very into looking at
reddit and digging into the fan base
response so was there anything
particular you took from the response to
season one that we can actually now see
you adding to geralt in season two
yes uh the biggest piece was i wanted to
represent
as much of a book accurate geralt as
possible and
it was and a lot of the fans did as well
and so i campaigned really hard to make
sure that he was
um
more verbose um he sounded more
intellectual his his choice of words was
was more thought out and
that his approach to
to cyrilla wasn't and everyone else
wasn't antagonistic because
it
initially came across as he was just
grumpy all the time with everyone and
everything and i really wanted to show
this three-dimensional character where
instead of him fighting with everyone uh
it whether it be cirilla or whether it
be uh the witches i wanted to show him
be intellectual and thoughtful and yes
have disagreements but
also
show his approach as someone who's been
alive for 70 plus years
there's he's not going to be a fool and
so when he's trying to draw information
out of syria and find out what her story
is and what she's about he's not going
to like push her into a corner and and
start shouting at her until she gives
her information he's going to tell a
story of his own for example and then
wait and see what she has to say and if
she doesn't say anything then ask ask a
question or tell another story until
eventually
she feels comfortable and she feels in
the company of someone
who has also been through traumatic
experiences so she can then share and
that was really really important for me
so he wasn't just this two-dimensional
grumpy snowman and in fact he was he was
a three-dimensional character and it's
going to be tough to do the stuff which
is as brilliant as sapkowski's writing
but it's something i'm always going to
campaign for and
it's hopefully fit into the vision of
the show
it's funny you say that because one of
my favorite parts of season one and your
work is geralt there and now even more
so in season two is you know how you
explore what it means to be a witch or
that hardened exterior but while letting
just enough emotion slip through so with
everything you just said in mind in this
particular season was there any specific
moment where you found yourself
workshopping or weighing that balance of
geralt's tough exterior and letting him
express some degree of warmth the most
i i wanted to lean hard into the
emotionality of garrett this season
because we have the access point for it
we have him with his his witcher
brothers and also with someone who he's
protecting and so
i i wanted to show a lot more of it and
there's
also a another relationship which
develops in a certain way um as the
season goes on um i don't think i think
even you haven't seen that um with only
six episodes but it's uh it's i
i i really led as hard into it as
possible and especially with vestemir
and kim bodney and i worked very hard on
um trying to bring that emotional
connection in rather than just
antagonistic men um who were grumpy
living in the mountains telling each
other off for everything we wanted to
make it more about a brotherhood and
i've certainly found in my experience
with people who are
hardened warriors and i i know a few of
them uh they tend to be the most
emotionally connected of us all
and it's something i really wanted to
portray with these guys and so it's
difficult to name any one scene but
anything involving uh vesamir and
anything involving cyrilla or indeed uh
there's there's a scene i think it's in
episode
six might be five or six
where we see him more emotional
and
and i
that was important to me to show that he
does have these connections um with
the people and things that he loves
i think i know what moment you're
hinting at there um before they kick me
out of here i did want to squeeze in one
superman question because it's something
that i think about a lot because i'm one
of the many who sits here and says like
i want henry to keep playing superman i
want a man of steel to like i could say
it all day long but then i stop myself
and i wonder
what do you get from returning to the
role what's something about your craft
and your growth as an actor in general
that you still think you have left to
get from returning to that role
um i wouldn't say it's about uh
the craft or me as an actor
uh i'd say it's about
i it is personal to a degree but it's
as much as i felt like man of steel was
a
a wonderful opening story an origin
story to superman it left a lot of space
for him to grow beyond that and become
the hero that we recognize
batman v superman took a hard turn down
a darker route and it was it was a
batman perspective story
and so it didn't really show the aspects
of superman which i was very very keen
to show superman sorry justice league
snyder card definitely lent into that a
bit more i had a bit more of a um a
gentleness to the tone of the thing um
but i would love to to have the
opportunity to play
the superman that we all know and love
um from the comics um as a as a
continuation of his development and and
we see the hero that would be really
really exciting for me uh because
there's so much
there is an opportunity to tell a lot of
interesting story there it's just about
finding the right hooks to have a
character that
is as
as good and idealistic as superman um
there are there are wonderful
opportunities to delve into
what it what it's like to exist as him
and and those hardships that come with
that um when you have to save everyone
how hard is that on you and that could
be that could be an interesting line to
run
i will take that i'll take anything you
want to do you always deliver i love the
witcher huge congratulations on season
two
thank you very much thank you